This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.|||这是一个 I-Heart 播客。真人保证。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.|||让自己经历一些磨难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿势从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。也就是数字 2 percent，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从 1979 年开始，那对我和来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.|||我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.|||在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.|||迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, thank you so much for joining me for another episode. This topic has been on my mind for some time. And I honestly think it's mandatory information, mandatory learning for those of us in our 20s, as I'm sure many of you are. And of course, with the holiday season and New Year's around the corner, I thought this just might be the best time to have a really deep conversation about personal and emotional boundaries. I think this time of the year is super important for us to reflect on what it is about our lives, about our relationships, that we want to improve and how it is that we want to treat ourselves and more importantly, how it is that we want others to treat us as well. And of course, I think many of us are travelling home to see our families. I think it's such a great time to talk about boundaries,
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, thank you so much for joining me for another episode. This topic has been on my mind for some time. And I honestly think it's mandatory information, mandatory learning for those of us in our 20s, as I'm sure many of you are. And of course, with the holiday season and New Year's around the corner, I thought this just might be the best time to have a really deep conversation about personal and emotional boundaries. I think this time of the year is super important for us to reflect on what it is about our lives, about our relationships, that we want to improve and how it is that we want to treat ourselves and more importantly, how it is that we want others to treat us as well. And of course, I think many of us are travelling home to see our families. I think it's such a great time to talk about boundaries,|||大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，非常感谢大家和我一起收听又一期节目。这个话题在我脑海中盘旋了一段时间。老实说，我认为对于我们这些二十多岁的人来说，这是必修的信息，必修的课程，我确信你们很多人也是如此。当然，随着节日季和新年的临近，我觉得这正是就个人和情感边界展开深入探讨的最佳时机。我认为每年的这个时候对于我们来说超级重要，我们可以借此反思我们生活中、我们关系中想要改善的部分，以及我们希望如何对待自己，更重要的是，我们希望别人如何对待我们。当然，我想很多人都要回家看望家人。我认为这是一个谈论边界的绝佳时机，
especially with family members, especially with distant relatives, all of those things. So today we are going to break down the psychology behind how we can establish sustainable and realistic boundaries in our 20s. I think that term, I think the idea of a boundary, the concept of boundaries, is talked about so much in psychology and self-improvement, but often the true meaning of what it means is not always clear, or the idea of what a boundary is
especially with family members, especially with distant relatives, all of those things. So today we are going to break down the psychology behind how we can establish sustainable and realistic boundaries in our 20s. I think that term, I think the idea of a boundary, the concept of boundaries, is talked about so much in psychology and self-improvement, but often the true meaning of what it means is not always clear, or the idea of what a boundary is|||尤其是和家庭成员之间，尤其是和远房亲戚之间，所有这些。所以今天我们将剖析背后的心理学，探讨如何在二十多岁时建立可持续且切合实际的边界。我认为那个词，我认为边界的想法，边界的概念，在心理学和自我提升中被讨论得太多了，但通常它真正的含义并不总是那么清晰，或者关于边界是什么的想法
is sometimes warped into something entirely different to its true meaning. Boundaries are meant to keep us safe, they're meant to keep us secure, and they help us improve our relationships, not just with others, but with ourselves. So in this episode, I really want to dispel some of that ambiguity about what exactly boundaries are. We're going to talk about the equation and the makeup of a healthy boundary, why we need boundaries to flourish in our lives, how to set boundaries, the consequences of not having them. And finally, what do we do when no matter how hard we try, someone keeps violating those expectations we have for them and those expectations about how we want to be treated. So so much valuable content and so many incredible findings and tips from psychology in this
is sometimes warped into something entirely different to its true meaning. Boundaries are meant to keep us safe, they're meant to keep us secure, and they help us improve our relationships, not just with others, but with ourselves. So in this episode, I really want to dispel some of that ambiguity about what exactly boundaries are. We're going to talk about the equation and the makeup of a healthy boundary, why we need boundaries to flourish in our lives, how to set boundaries, the consequences of not having them. And finally, what do we do when no matter how hard we try, someone keeps violating those expectations we have for them and those expectations about how we want to be treated. So so much valuable content and so many incredible findings and tips from psychology in this|||有时会被扭曲成与其本意完全不同的东西。边界是为了保证我们的安全，为了让我们感到安心，它们帮助我们改善关系，不仅是与他人的关系，还有与我们自己的关系。所以在这一期节目中，我真的很想消除关于边界到底是什么的一些模糊性。我们将讨论健康边界的构成公式、为什么我们需要边界来让生活繁荣发展、如何设定边界、没有边界的后果。最后，当我们无论怎么努力，总有人不断违背我们对他们的期望以及我们对被对待方式的期望时，我们该怎么办？所以这一期有太多宝贵的内容，以及来自心理学的众多不可思议的发现和技巧
episode, I know boundary setting is definitely something I've had to learn in 2022 and maybe it's something that you are also working on. So I think it's absolutely so valuable. You know, we cannot give people unlimited access to us. We can't let people walk all over us or sacrifice. us, our own well-being for others, and our 20s are this absolutely crucial, crucial time to really start establishing how we want people to treat us. And not only that, but how we can teach people how to treat us through realistic and healthy boundary setting. So I'm very excited for this episode. The research was so fascinating. And I know that I learned a lot. So I hope that you will too, and without further ado, let's talk boundaries. What are they? Why do we need them?
episode, I know boundary setting is definitely something I've had to learn in 2022 and maybe it's something that you are also working on. So I think it's absolutely so valuable. You know, we cannot give people unlimited access to us. We can't let people walk all over us or sacrifice. us, our own well-being for others, and our 20s are this absolutely crucial, crucial time to really start establishing how we want people to treat us. And not only that, but how we can teach people how to treat us through realistic and healthy boundary setting. So I'm very excited for this episode. The research was so fascinating. And I know that I learned a lot. So I hope that you will too, and without further ado, let's talk boundaries. What are they? Why do we need them?|||我知道设定边界绝对是我在 2022 年必须学会的事情，也许这也是你正在努力的事情。所以我认为这绝对是非常宝贵的。你知道的，我们不能让人无限制地接近我们。我们不能让别人践踏我们或者为了他人牺牲我们自己、我们的幸福，我们的二十岁是开始真正确立我们希望别人如何对待我们的绝对关键、关键时期。不仅如此，我们还要通过现实且健康的边界设定来教会别人如何对待我们。所以我对这一期非常兴奋。这项研究太迷人了。我知道我学到了很多。所以我希望你也能有所收获，废话不多说，我们来聊聊边界。它们是什么？为什么我们需要它们？
And how to stick to them. So let's start at the very beginning and understand what exactly is a boundary. This term has become such a huge part of the psychobabble in recent years, especially in terms of the expectations and the guidelines that we set for our families, our partners, our friends. I think it's fantastic that we have become so much better at being aware of what we need in our lives and that we've also become equipped with the language to kind of stand up for ourselves and establish agency over our most important relationships. One of my friends told me this the other day. She has, I think, a sister who's in primary school, and it's even become part of some of our early childhood curriculum teaching kids about boundaries. And I think that is so special and so
And how to stick to them. So let's start at the very beginning and understand what exactly is a boundary. This term has become such a huge part of the psychobabble in recent years, especially in terms of the expectations and the guidelines that we set for our families, our partners, our friends. I think it's fantastic that we have become so much better at being aware of what we need in our lives and that we've also become equipped with the language to kind of stand up for ourselves and establish agency over our most important relationships. One of my friends told me this the other day. She has, I think, a sister who's in primary school, and it's even become part of some of our early childhood curriculum teaching kids about boundaries. And I think that is so special and so|||以及如何坚持它们。让我们从最初开始，了解到底什么是边界。近年来，这个词已经成为心理学术语中的一个重要部分，特别是在我们为家人、伴侣、朋友设定的期望和准则方面。我认为太棒了，我们现在能更好地意识到我们在生活中需要什么，并且我们还掌握了语言，能够为自己挺身而出，并在我们最重要的关系中建立自主权。我的一个朋友前几天跟我说过这件事。她有一个上小学的妹妹，据我所知，这甚至已经成为我们幼儿课程的一部分，教导孩子们关于边界的知识。我认为这是非常特别且
amazing to be teaching children from a really early age, how to decide and determine how they want to be treated. I think that's fantastic. So boundaries are essentially rules or limits that a person decides upon in order to create a reasonable, a safe, a secure environment for themselves, particularly in terms of their relationships. So boundaries, they are essentially emotional, physical, mental, even financial limits that we don't want the people in our lives to cross. And they are so crucial for establishing healthy relationships because if we let people cross into a terrain or an area of our lives or overstep how we deserve to be treated, we can be left feeling really offended, really hurt and upset, and that's not how we want to feel.
amazing to be teaching children from a really early age, how to decide and determine how they want to be treated. I think that's fantastic. So boundaries are essentially rules or limits that a person decides upon in order to create a reasonable, a safe, a secure environment for themselves, particularly in terms of their relationships. So boundaries, they are essentially emotional, physical, mental, even financial limits that we don't want the people in our lives to cross. And they are so crucial for establishing healthy relationships because if we let people cross into a terrain or an area of our lives or overstep how we deserve to be treated, we can be left feeling really offended, really hurt and upset, and that's not how we want to feel.|||了不起的，从小就教导孩子如何决定和确定他们希望被如何对待。我认为这太棒了。所以边界本质上是一个人为了给自己创造一个合理、安全、安心的环境而自行决定的规则或限制，特别是在人际关系方面。所以边界，它们本质上是我们不希望生命中的人跨越的情感、身体、精神甚至财务限制。对于建立健康的人际关系，它们是如此至关重要，因为如果我们允许别人闯入我们生活的某个领地或区域，或者超越了我们理应受到的待遇，我们最终会感到非常被冒犯、非常受伤和沮丧，而这并不是我们想要的感觉。
I think it's also a disservice to our relationships if we don't establish boundaries within them because it can result in a lot of built-up, long-term, unresolved resentment. It's important to note here that boundaries, there are a sense. essentially a really critical way that we're able to take charge of our own happiness. Because people are going to treat us the way that we allow them to, right? I think generally the people we surround ourselves with, I would hope, are really good people. But they're often treating you in the way that they would like to be treated and how they expect to be treated. And of course, they're just applying their own internal perspective to your behaviors
I think it's also a disservice to our relationships if we don't establish boundaries within them because it can result in a lot of built-up, long-term, unresolved resentment. It's important to note here that boundaries, there are a sense. essentially a really critical way that we're able to take charge of our own happiness. Because people are going to treat us the way that we allow them to, right? I think generally the people we surround ourselves with, I would hope, are really good people. But they're often treating you in the way that they would like to be treated and how they expect to be treated. And of course, they're just applying their own internal perspective to your behaviors|||我认为如果在关系中不建立边界，这也是对关系的一种伤害，因为它会导致大量积压的、长期的、未解决的怨恨。这里需要注意的是，边界，它们在某种意义上本质上是我们掌控自己幸福的一种非常关键的方式。因为别人会以我们允许的方式对待我们，对吧？我认为总的来说，我希望我们身边的人都是很好的人。但他们通常会以他们希望被对待的方式以及他们期望被对待的方式来对待你。当然，他们只是将自己内部的视角套用到你的行为
and interactions. You know, for example, maybe one of your friends is really good at instantly replying to messages. You know, they're always on their phone, so they have no problem getting back to you ASAP. So when they message you, they expect the same thing back. And maybe they become upset or they feel neglected when you don't do that. But for you, right, you might need time away from technology or you just might feel really overwhelmed with replying. as soon as you see a message, you know, it might just be that you're busy and you don't have time to get to it. So by recognizing that and having this boundary that, you know, hey, I'm not going to reply instantly. I'm not going to be able to get back to you as soon as possible. And having
and interactions. You know, for example, maybe one of your friends is really good at instantly replying to messages. You know, they're always on their phone, so they have no problem getting back to you ASAP. So when they message you, they expect the same thing back. And maybe they become upset or they feel neglected when you don't do that. But for you, right, you might need time away from technology or you just might feel really overwhelmed with replying. as soon as you see a message, you know, it might just be that you're busy and you don't have time to get to it. So by recognizing that and having this boundary that, you know, hey, I'm not going to reply instantly. I'm not going to be able to get back to you as soon as possible. And having|||和互动中。你知道的，比如，可能你的一个朋友非常擅长秒回信息。你知道的，他们总是拿着手机，所以尽快回复你对他们来说毫无问题。所以当他们给你发信息时，他们也期望得到同样的对待。而当你没有这样做时，他们可能会感到沮丧或觉得自己被忽视了。但对你来说，对吧，你可能需要一段时间远离科技产品，或者你可能只是觉得一看到信息就必须回复让人感到压力山大，你知道的，可能只是因为你很忙，没时间处理。所以通过认识到这一点并设定这样一个边界，你知道的，嘿，我不会秒回。我可能无法尽快回复你。并且进行
an open conversation about this, about how much time, how much energy you can give that friend, you allow yourselves to have a more open and a more respectful relationship with each other without having those undue pressure or expectations. Obviously, that's a pretty small boundary, right? It's a pretty negligent boundary. When we think about other ones, like sexual boundaries or physical boundaries, it can get a lot more complicated, but it can also get a lot more, I wouldn't say significant, but important to really understand what you need
an open conversation about this, about how much time, how much energy you can give that friend, you allow yourselves to have a more open and a more respectful relationship with each other without having those undue pressure or expectations. Obviously, that's a pretty small boundary, right? It's a pretty negligent boundary. When we think about other ones, like sexual boundaries or physical boundaries, it can get a lot more complicated, but it can also get a lot more, I wouldn't say significant, but important to really understand what you need|||一次坦诚的对话，关于你能给那个朋友多少时间、多少精力，你们就允许彼此建立一种更开放、更互相尊重、而又没有那些不应有的压力或期望的关系。显然，这是一个相当小的边界，对吧？这是一个很容易被忽视的边界。当我们想到其他的，比如性边界或身体边界时，事情可能会变得复杂得多，但它也可能会变得——我不会说更有意义，但对于真正理解你的需求而言非常重要
and what you require from someone else and what your kind of deal breakers are, what your no-go zones are. one of the big realizations I think I had when I first really began thinking about boundaries a little bit more and I guess maturing as a person overall is that people cannot read your mind and they are not automatically going to know exactly what you need and what you expect. That is kind of your duty. It's kind of your duty to discover that about yourself and it's also your responsibility. to make that known. Boundaries are also super important because they help define your sense of self by separating your needs and desires from others. I think this is really common in our 20s, especially for those of us who are like serial people places. It's really common to find
and what you require from someone else and what your kind of deal breakers are, what your no-go zones are. one of the big realizations I think I had when I first really began thinking about boundaries a little bit more and I guess maturing as a person overall is that people cannot read your mind and they are not automatically going to know exactly what you need and what you expect. That is kind of your duty. It's kind of your duty to discover that about yourself and it's also your responsibility. to make that known. Boundaries are also super important because they help define your sense of self by separating your needs and desires from others. I think this is really common in our 20s, especially for those of us who are like serial people places. It's really common to find|||以及你对别人的要求是什么，你的底线是什么，你的禁区是什么。我认为当我第一次开始更多地思考边界问题，并且作为一个整体在为人处世上变得更加成熟时，我最大的感悟之一就是：人们无法读懂你的心思，他们也不会自动准确地知道你需要什么和期望什么。这可以说是你的职责。发现关于你自己的这一点可以说是你的职责，这也是你的责任。让别人知道这一点。边界也超级重要，因为它们通过将你的需求和欲望与他人区分开来，来帮助定义你的自我意识。我认为这在我们的二十多岁时非常普遍，特别是对于我们当中那些惯于讨好别人的人来说。你会经常发现
that our needs are subsumed by those of others. And we almost place what we, want as less important to what others want from us. I don't think that's anyone's fault, right? That's not your fault. It's not their fault either. In most cases, people are just meeting you where you are prepared to meet them. And I think that's where boundaries come in, right? Because people, you know, are going to take as much as you give. Of course, there are obviously a lot of instances in which people are actively manipulative or prepared to push us further than we would like to go, in which case I would say boundaries are more important. But in general, when we set boundaries early and intentionally, we can avoid some of those consequences of
that our needs are subsumed by those of others. And we almost place what we, want as less important to what others want from us. I don't think that's anyone's fault, right? That's not your fault. It's not their fault either. In most cases, people are just meeting you where you are prepared to meet them. And I think that's where boundaries come in, right? Because people, you know, are going to take as much as you give. Of course, there are obviously a lot of instances in which people are actively manipulative or prepared to push us further than we would like to go, in which case I would say boundaries are more important. But in general, when we set boundaries early and intentionally, we can avoid some of those consequences of|||我们的需求被别人的需求所吞没。我们几乎把我们自己想要的东西看得比别人对我们的要求更不重要。我认为这并不是任何人的错，对吧？这不是你的错。也不是他们的错。在大多数情况下，人们只是在你能接受的程度上与你相处。我认为这就是边界发挥作用的地方，对吧？因为你知道的，别人会索取你所给予的一切。当然，显然有很多情况下，人们具有积极的操控性，或者准备把我们推得比我们愿意去的更远，在这种情况下，我会说边界更加重要。但总的来说，当我们尽早且有意地设定边界时，我们可以避免一些诸如此类的后果：
feeling like someone's taking advantage of us or treating us in a way that we don't want to be treated, either wittingly or unwittingly. I think this is a great time to jump into the different types of boundaries and some of the examples. I think that boundaries with our closest relationships, you know, our partners, our parents, our siblings, our friends, they're often the ones that receive the most attention and for a good reason, right, for a very good reason. These are the people that we're closest to, who we give the most to and know us the best, but they're also the people who have the most access to our lives.
feeling like someone's taking advantage of us or treating us in a way that we don't want to be treated, either wittingly or unwittingly. I think this is a great time to jump into the different types of boundaries and some of the examples. I think that boundaries with our closest relationships, youour partners, our parents, our siblings, our friends, they're often the ones that receive the most attention and for a good reason, right, for a very good reason. These are the people that we're closest to, who we give the most to and know us the best, but they're also the people who have the most access to our lives.|||感觉有人在占我们便宜，或者以我们不希望的方式对待我们，无论是有意还是无意。我认为现在是切入不同类型的边界以及一些示例的好时机。我认为我们与最亲密关系（我们的伴侣、父母、兄弟姐妹、朋友）之间的边界，往往是受到最多关注的边界，这是有充分理由的，对吧，有非常充分的理由。这些人是我们最亲近的人，我们为他们付出最多，他们最了解我们，但他们也是对我们的生活拥有最多接触权限的人。
and with that comes the greatest ability to impact us. So setting clear expectations and boundaries in these relationships, I think is really crucial for our well-being in all domains of our lives. There are generally around seven different types of boundaries that I think that we would often think of. So almost seven different categories. The first I think is physical, a physical boundary. And this often relates to our personal space, our physical space. For example, you know, you might not like it when people touch you without asking
and with that comes the greatest ability to impact us. So setting clear expectations and boundaries in these relationships, I think is really crucial for our well-being in all domains of our lives. There are generally around seven different types of boundaries that I think that we would often think of. So almost seven different categories. The first I think is physical, a physical boundary. And this often relates to our personal space, our physical space. For example, you know, you might not like it when people touch you without asking|||伴随而来的也是对我们最大的影响力。所以在这些关系中设定明确的期望和边界，我认为对于我们生活中各个领域的幸福感至关重要。总的来说，大约有七种不同类型的边界是我们经常会想到的。所以几乎有七个不同的类别。我认为第一个是物理的，物理边界。这通常与我们的个人空间、我们的物理空间有关。例如，你知道的，你可能不喜欢别人不经允许就触碰你
or enter into your personal space. It makes you feel uncomfortable. It also may be about how people treat your physical space or your environment and wanting that to be protected. Like you don't want people to drink in your house or bring drugs into your space or leave their rubbish around. That's a physical boundary. That's you making a decision about how you want your physical environment to feel like, how you want your physical space to be respected. I used to live in the sharehouse when I was in Canberra and we have this friend who would always come over and he would always bring like takeaway food with them. I swear like every time this person left, they would just leave their rubbish all around the kitchen and the dining room.
or enter into your personal space. It makes you feel uncomfortable. It also may be about how people treat your physical space or your environment and wanting that to be protected. Like you don't want people to drink in your house or bring drugs into your space or leave their rubbish around. That's a physical boundary. That's you making a decision about how you want your physical environment to feel like, how you want your physical space to be respected. I used to live in the sharehouse when I was in Canberra and we have this friend who would always come over and he would always bring like takeaway food with them. I swear like every time this person left, they would just leave their rubbish all around the kitchen and the dining room.|||或进入你的个人空间。这会让你感到不舒服。这也可能关乎别人如何对待你的物理空间或你的环境，并希望得到保护。比如你不希望别人在你的房子里喝酒，或者把毒品带进你的空间，或者到处乱扔垃圾。这就是物理边界。这是你做出的一个决定，关于你希望你的物理环境感觉如何，你希望你的物理空间如何受到尊重。我以前在堪培拉合租时住过一个合租房，我们有个朋友总是过来，他每次来都会带外卖食品什么的。我发誓，每次这个人离开时，他都会把垃圾扔得厨房和餐厅到处都是。
And let me tell you that annoyed me so much because I, like a contained mess or no mess at all. So I definitely established a boundary there and was like, you cannot leave your mess around my house, please and thank you. And I think establishing a boundary around how you like your personal space and your environment to be protected is super valid. It's so valid. Sexual boundaries are also one that I think gets a lot of attention for all the right reasons. and these kind of boundaries, they essentially protect your right to consent, to ask for what you'd like, and to be honest about your partner and honest with your partner about things like their sexual history, their preferences, things like that. And they define what kind of sexual touch or intimacy you want, how often, when, where, and with whom.
And let me tell you that annoyed me so much because I, like a contained mess or no mess at all. So I definitely established a boundary there and was like, you cannot leave your mess around my house, please and thank you. And I think establishing a boundary around how you like your personal space and your environment to be protected is super valid. It's so valid. Sexual boundaries are also one that I think gets a lot of attention for all the right reasons. and these kind of boundaries, they essentially protect your right to consent, to ask for what you'd like, and to be honest about your partner and honest with your partner about things like their sexual history, their preferences, things like that. And they define what kind of sexual touch or intimacy you want, how often, when, where, and with whom.|||老实说，这让我非常恼火，因为我喜欢受控的杂乱或者根本没有杂乱。所以我绝对在那里建立了一个边界，并说：请谢谢你，你不能把你的垃圾留在我的屋子周围。我认为围绕你喜欢个人空间和环境如何受到保护来建立边界是超级有效的。实在是太有效了。性边界也是我认为由于各种正确原因而备受关注的一个领域，这类边界本质上保护了你同意的权利、索取你想要的东西的权利，以及对你的伴侣诚实、并与伴侣坦诚相待的权利，比如关于他们的性史、他们的偏好之类的事情。它们界定了你想要的性触碰或亲密关系的种类、频率、时间、地点以及对象。
I think, for example, a sexual boundary may be that you don't want to have sex when you're drunk or be treated in a certain way when you're with someone. Once again, so valid. And I think sexual boundaries in particular, I wasn't, I was about to say like sexual boundaries need to be ultimately respected, but all boundaries do sexual boundaries amongst them. But I think that they can be something that's really difficult to sometimes have a conversation about. I don't think that we as a society are very good at having conversations about sex and having conversations about the boundaries that exist around sexual intimacy.
I think, for example, a sexual boundary may be that you don't want to have sex when you're drunk or be treated in a certain way when you're with someone. Once again, so valid. And I think sexual boundaries in particular, I wasn't, I was about to say like sexual boundaries need to be ultimately respected, but all boundaries do sexual boundaries amongst them. But I think that they can be something that's really difficult to sometimes have a conversation about. I don't think that we as a society are very good at having conversations about sex and having conversations about the boundaries that exist around sexual intimacy.|||我想，例如，性边界可能是你不想在喝醉时发生性行为，或者在与某人在一起时不想受到某种特定的对待。再次强调，太对了。我认为性边界尤其如此，我本来想说像性边界需要最终得到尊重，但所有边界都一样，性边界也在其中。但我认为，有时它们可能是非常难以启齿、难以进行对话的事情。我不认为我们作为社会非常擅长进行关于性的对话，以及关于围绕性亲密关系存在的边界的对话。
I feel like that's a whole other episode. But the next kind of boundary is emotional and mental boundaries. Obviously, I think all boundaries are created equal, but this one has a particular, I don't know, a particular space in my heart. and I think is often what we think about when we talk about boundaries. Your emotional and your mental boundaries, they protect your right to have your feelings respected and to hold your own beliefs about the world with the caveat that those beliefs aren't obviously hurtful or reduce someone else's worth.
I feel like that's a whole other episode. But the next kind of boundary is emotional and mental boundaries. Obviously, I think all boundaries are created equal, but this one has a particular, I don't know, a particular space in my heart. and I think is often what we think about when we talk about boundaries. Your emotional and your mental boundaries, they protect your right to have your feelings respected and to hold your own beliefs about the world with the caveat that those beliefs aren't obviously hurtful or reduce someone else's worth.|||我觉得那是另一个完整的话题了。但接下来的一种边界是情感和心理边界。显然，我认为所有的边界都是平等的，但这一种在我的心中有着特殊的——我不知道，特殊的地位，并且我认为这往往是我们谈论边界时所想到的。你的情感和心理边界，它们保护了你的权利：你的感受受到尊重，并且对世界持有你自己的信念，但前提是这些信念没有明显地伤害到别人或贬低别人的价值。
Like, I mean, you can't be like I have an emotional boundary that I'm allowed to be sexist or racist. No, no, that's not how it works. right. It's more so like being able to say that you don't feel like sharing something or you don't want to discuss a particular topic that's harmful to you or standing up for yourself when someone belittles you or speaks you in a certain way, criticizes your decisions or how you look. These are things that are related to how you feel mentally and emotionally when you're around others. Spiritual boundaries was one that I found really interesting, actually. I'm not a very spiritual or religious person anymore. I used to be quite, that used to be the case, but not anymore.
Like, I mean, you can't be like I have an emotional boundary that I'm allowed to be sexist or racist. No, no, that's not how it works. right. It's more so like being able to say that you don't feel like sharing something or you don't want to discuss a particular topic that's harmful to you or standing up for yourself when someone belittles you or speaks you in a certain way, criticizes your decisions or how you look. These are things that are related to how you feel mentally and emotionally when you're around others. Spiritual boundaries was one that I found really interesting, actually. I'm not a very spiritual or religious person anymore. I used to be quite, that used to be the case, but not anymore.|||比如说，我的意思是，你不能说我有一个情感边界，允许我存在性别歧视或种族歧视。不，不，事情不是这样的。对。它更多的是能够说出你不想分享某些事情，或者你不想讨论对你有伤害的特定话题，或者当有人贬低你、以某种特定方式对你说话、批评你的决定或你的外表时，为自己挺身而出。这些都与你和他人在一起时的心理和情感感受有关。精神边界实际上是我觉得非常有趣的一种。我不再是一个非常注重精神或宗教信仰的人了。我以前挺是的，过去确实如此，但现在不再是了。
So I had never really thought about how religion and spirituality could be involved in boundary setting. But spiritual boundaries, essentially they protect your right to believe what you would like about the world and practice your own spiritual beliefs. For example, a spiritual or religious boundary may be that you would like, you know, a dedicated five-minute break throughout the workday to pray or time out of the week to go to church or synagogue or a mosque, even if, for example, your partner doesn't share that belief. It's a boundary that allows you to have access to your spiritual life and the spiritual side of your life without feeling like it's being compromised by someone else. And it goes the other way, right? Like it may be that you don't want to discuss
So I had never really thought about how religion and spirituality could be involved in boundary setting. But spiritual boundaries, essentially they protect your right to believe what you would like about the world and practice your own spiritual beliefs. For example, a spiritual or religious boundary may be that you would like, you know, a dedicated five-minute break throughout the workday to pray or time out of the week to go to church or synagogue or a mosque, even if, for example, your partner doesn't share that belief. It's a boundary that allows you to have access to your spiritual life and the spiritual side of your life without feeling like it's being compromised by someone else. And it goes the other way, right? Like it may be that you don't want to discuss|||所以我从未真正想过宗教和灵性如何能够融入边界设定中。但精神边界，本质上它们保护了你的权利：你可以相信你对世界的看法，并践行你自己的精神信仰。例如，一个精神或宗教边界可能是你希望，你知道的，在整个工作日中有专门的五分钟休息时间来祈祷，或者每周腾出时间去教堂、犹太会堂或清真寺，即便例如你的伙伴并不持有这种信仰。这是一个边界，它允许你接触你的精神生活和你生活的精神面貌，而不会觉得它被别人妥协了。反之亦然，对吧？就像可能是你不想讨论
religion with your family because it gets heated and it's unproductive. That's also a boundary that you're allowed to set. Maybe it's one that you're thinking about as we approach the Christmas and the holiday season. Financial boundaries, this is an interesting one. They really concern how you would like to treat and use your financial resources as well as your possessions. You know, things like, please don't borrow my car without asking, or being able to ask your friends to choose a cheaper restaurant because you're saving. I did a whole episode on this actually. I think it's called financial anxiety and money in your 20s
religion with your family because it gets heated and it's unproductive. That's also a boundary that you're allowed to set. Maybe it's one that you're thinking about as we approach the Christmas and the holiday season. Financial boundaries, this is an interesting one. They really concern how you would like to treat and use your financial resources as well as your possessions. You know, things like, please don't borrow my car without asking, or being able to ask your friends to choose a cheaper restaurant because you're saving. I did a whole episode on this actually. I think it's called financial anxiety and money in your 20s|||与家人的宗教问题，因为这会变得情绪激动且没有建设性。这也是你被允许设定的一个边界。随着圣诞节和节日季的临近，这或许正是你正在考虑的一个。财务边界，这是一个有趣的领域。它们真正关乎你希望如何对待和使用你的财务资源以及你的财产。你知道的，比如：请不要在未询问的情况下借我的车，或者因为你在存钱而能够要求你的朋友选择一家便宜一点的餐厅。事实上我为此做过一整期节目。我想它叫《财务焦虑与你二十多岁的金钱观》
that I think is so valuable for us in our 20s, especially when people are making super different. amounts of money. You know, I have friends who are still at uni or job hunting whilst others are working jobs with like crazy salaries. And I think we should all be able to enjoy our time together without feeling like our financial boundaries are being crossed and that the people who are closest to us are respectful of our financial situation. So yeah, financial boundaries can be things like, oh, I actually am not prepared to spend crazy amounts of money on like shared birthday gifts. And hopefully the people around you are really respectful of that.
that I think is so valuable for us in our 20s, especially when people are making super different. amounts of money. You know, I have friends who are still at uni or job hunting whilst others are working jobs with like crazy salaries. And I think we should all be able to enjoy our time together without feeling like our financial boundaries are being crossed and that the people who are closest to us are respectful of our financial situation. So yeah, financial boundaries can be things like, oh, I actually am not prepared to spend crazy amounts of money on like shared birthday gifts. And hopefully the people around you are really respectful of that.|||我认为这对我们二十多岁的人来说太有价值了，尤其是当人们赚取的金额截然不同时。你知道的，我有还在上大学或找工作的朋友，而其他人则在做着薪水高得离谱的工作。我认为我们都应该能够享受我们在一起的时光，而不用担心我们的财务边界被跨越，并且我们最亲近的人能够尊重我们的财务状况。所以，是的，财务边界可以是这样的：哦，我其实不准备在共同的生日礼物上花大笔的钱。希望你身边的人对此真的非常尊重。
Time boundaries. Time boundaries. I find these so interesting. I think I've said that about every single one. But time boundaries, often we put these in place to protect how we want to spend the hours in our day. And also how we want to spend our energy. They protect you from agreeing to do things that you don't want to do. from having people waste your time, from feeling overworked.
Time boundaries. Time boundaries. I find these so interesting. I think I've said that about every single one. But time boundaries, often we put these in place to protect how we want to spend the hours in our day. And also how we want to spend our energy. They protect you from agreeing to do things that you don't want to do. from having people waste your time, from feeling overworked.|||时间边界。时间边界。我觉得这些太有趣了。我想我对每一个都这么说过。但时间边界，我们通常设立这些是为了保护我们想如何度过一天中的时间。以及我们想如何消耗我们的精力。它们保护你免于答应去做你不想做的事情。免于被别人浪费时间，免于感到过度劳累。
My full-time workers who are listening, I feel like this one is a huge one if you found yourself in your first full-time nine-to-five job, establishing time boundaries around my free time, my personal time. It's something I'm so bad at. I am terrible at doing this to the point where I can be super burnt out and I'm still not able to set that limit for myself. I'm still not able to communicate that to other people and be like, hey, no, I have a boundary around this. You know, for example, being able to say that you reserve you time in the evenings or time to be social or that you can't spend, you know, a whole day with one of your
My full-time workers who are listening, I feel like this one is a huge one if you found yourself in your first full-time nine-to-five job, establishing time boundaries around my free time, my personal time. It's something I'm so bad at. I am terrible at doing this to the point where I can be super burnt out and I'm still not able to set that limit for myself. I'm still not able to communicate that to other people and be like, hey, no, I have a boundary around this. You know, for example, being able to say that you reserve you time in the evenings or time to be social or that you can't spend, you know, a whole day with one of your|||正在收听的全职工作者们，我觉得如果你们发现自己正在经历第一份九晚五的全职工作，这一条绝对是个巨头，即围绕我的空闲时间、我的个人时间建立时间边界。这是我极不擅长的事情。我在这方面简直糟透了，以至于我可能会严重职业倦怠，却仍然无法为自己设定那个界限。我依然无法将其传达给其他人并说：嘿，不，我在这方面有边界。你知道的，例如，能够说出你在晚上保留自己的时间，或者社交的时间，或者你不能花——你知道的，一整天的时间和你的某一个
friends. I think it's also an important one with Christmas and the holidays coming up to be able to set a boundary with your family even and say, you know, I can't spend every day. I'm not. day with you over the holidays because, you know, I want time to myself or to see my friends or to do something else to make me happy. Once again, time boundaries, super important. And then we have deal breakers or what I like to call like the miscellaneous or the other category. So these might be boundaries that don't really fit into any of the above that we've discussed. And they might be really niche? One of the big deal breakers, I think most of us have, is around infidelity. That's one that I think of quite a bit. I think it has a lot of links to sexual boundaries, but it's also
friends. I think it's also an important one with Christmas and the holidays coming up to be able to set a boundary with your family even and say, you know, I can't spend every day. I'm not. day with you over the holidays because, you know, I want time to myself or to see my friends or to do something else to make me happy. Once again, time boundaries, super important. And then we have deal breakers or what I like to call like the miscellaneous or the other category. So these might be boundaries that don't really fit into any of the above that we've discussed. And they might be really niche? One of the big deal breakers, I think most of us have, is around infidelity. That's one that I think of quite a bit. I think it has a lot of links to sexual boundaries, but it's also|||朋友在一起。随着圣诞节和假期的临近，这也是一个重要的方面，甚至可以与家人设定边界并说：你知道的，我不能每天都待在一起。我不是。假期里天天和你们在一起，因为，你知道的，我想要属于自己的时间，或者去看望朋友，或者做其他能让我快乐的事情。再次强调，时间边界，超级重要。然后我们有底线，或者我喜欢称之为杂项或其它类别。所以这些可能是并不太适合我们上面讨论过的任何一项的边界。而且它们可能非常小众？我认为我们大多数人都拥有的一个重大底线是关于不忠。这是我经常想到的一个。我认为它与性边界有很大联系，但它也是
an emotional and a mental boundary. It's a big no-no for me, you know, a big violation or grounds for ending a relationship even. You know, maybe it's that you don't want your parents to comment on your partner or your job. Completely right. reasonable or you don't want your housemates, I don't know, to cook meat in your frying pan. I feel like that's a bit of a physical boundary. But anyway, there are so many different categories of boundary. I found it so interesting to hear about all of these. And honestly, I think when we think about that massive landscape, you can have as many
an emotional and a mental boundary. It's a big no-no for me, you know, a big violation or grounds for ending a relationship even. You know, maybe it's that you don't want your parents to comment on your partner or your job. Completely right. reasonable or you don't want your housemates, I don't know, to cook meat in your frying pan. I feel like that's a bit of a physical boundary. But anyway, there are so many different categories of boundary. I found it so interesting to hear about all of these. And honestly, I think when we think about that massive landscape, you can have as many|||一个情感和心理边界。对我来说这是一个大忌，你知道的，这是一个严重的违规行为，甚至是结束一段关系的理由。你知道的，也许是你不想让父母评论你的伴侣或你的工作。完全正确。合理的，或者你可能不希望你的室友——我不知道——在你的平底锅里煮肉。我觉得这有点像物理边界。但无论如何，边界的类别实在是太多了。听到所有这些，我感到非常有趣。老实说，我认为当我们考虑到那个庞大的图景时，你可以拥有任意多的
boundaries as you would like in your life. Obviously, I don't think that that's necessary. and I don't think that it's particularly healthy to put that much pressure on the people in our lives to always act a certain way. But if that's what you decide to do, then go for it. You can have as many deal breakers as you want. You can choose whatever boundaries that you would like. Because at the end of the day, it's about how you want to be treated. and the environment that you expect to have.
boundaries as you would like in your life. Obviously, I don't think that that's necessary. and I don't think that it's particularly healthy to put that much pressure on the people in our lives to always act a certain way. But if that's what you decide to do, then go for it. You can have as many deal breakers as you want. You can choose whatever boundaries that you would like. Because at the end of the day, it's about how you want to be treated. and the environment that you expect to have.|||你想要的边界融入你的生活。显然，我认为这没有必要，而且给生活中的人们施加那么大的压力，要求他们总是以某种特定方式行事，我认为这并不是特别健康。但如果你决定这么做，那就去吧。你可以拥有任意多的底线。你可以选择任何你喜欢的边界。因为归根结底，这关乎你希望被如何对待，以及你期望拥有的环境。
Also, I think with many of these, yes, you can set these boundaries with other people, but you can also set individual and internal boundaries around how you want to treat yourself. You know, for example, this year I made a big pact with myself, a very strict boundary, that I didn't want to say negative things or talk down to myself internally.
Also, I think with many of these, yes, you can set these boundaries with other people, but you can also set individual and internal boundaries around how you want to treat yourself. You know, for example, this year I made a big pact with myself, a very strict boundary, that I didn't want to say negative things or talk down to myself internally.|||此外，我认为对于其中许多方面，是的，你可以与其他人设定这些边界，但你也可以围绕你希望如何对待自己来设定个人和内心的边界。你知道的，例如，今年我和自己定下一个巨大的契约，一个非常严格的边界，那就是我不想在内心说消极的话或贬低自己。
And when I did that, I wanted to make sure I corrected that behavior and treated myself in a way that I would want others to treat me. So super nuanced, right? You can have these boundaries around how others treat you, but you can also have personal and individual boundaries as well. So now that we have a bit of a lay of the land, how can we actually go about setting healthy and realistic boundaries with others in a way that is firstly effective, but also sustainable and gets us our desired outcome. Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system and my gut health. And with
And when I did that, I wanted to make sure I corrected that behavior and treated myself in a way that I would want others to treat me. So super nuanced, right? You can have these boundaries around how others treat you, but you can also have personal and individual boundaries as well. So now that we have a bit of a lay of the land, how can we actually go about setting healthy and realistic boundaries with others in a way that is firstly effective, but also sustainable and gets us our desired outcome. Our next partner has a product I use literally every day. I started taking AG1 because I've been on a bit of a health journey. I wanted to take better care of my immune system and my gut health. And with|||当我这样做的时候，我想确保我纠正了这种行为，并以我希望别人对待我的方式对待我自己。所以超级微妙，对吧？你可以围绕别人如何对待你设定这些边界，但你也可以拥有个人和专属的边界。好了，既然我们对这个领域有了大致了解，我们究竟该如何与他人设定健康且现实的边界，使其首先有效，同时又可持续，并为我们带来想要的结果呢？我们的下一位合作伙伴拥有一款我几乎每天都在使用的产品。我开始服用 AG1，因为我一直在经历一段健康之旅。我想更好地照顾我的免疫系统和肠道健康。通过
one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff and it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. It's just one simple micro habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly and athletic greens is also a climate neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different. pills and supplements to look after your health. And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give
one delicious scoop of AG1, you're essentially absorbing 75 high quality vitamins, minerals, probiotics, all that good stuff and it's really great for your nervous system and your immune system. It's just one simple micro habit that you can incorporate into your daily life with big benefits. It's super lifestyle friendly and athletic greens is also a climate neutral certified company, which we absolutely love on the show. Right now, it is time to reclaim your health and arm your immune system with a convenient daily nutrition. It's just one scoop in a cup of water every day. That's it. No need for a million different. pills and supplements to look after your health. And to make it easy, Athletic Greens is going to give|||一勺美味的 AG1，你基本上可以吸收 75 种高品质的维生素、矿物质、益生菌以及所有这些好东西，它对你的神经系统和免疫系统真的很好。这只是一个你可以融入日常生活中的简单微习惯，却能带来巨大的益处。它对生活方式超级友好，而且 Athletic Greens 还是一家气候中和认证公司，我们在节目中绝对喜欢这一点。现在，是时候重获健康，用便捷的日常营养武装你的免疫系统了。每天只需在杯水里加一勺。就这样。不需要成百上千种不同的药丸和补充剂来照顾你的健康。为了方便起见，Athletic Greens 将会为你提供
you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash gemma. Again, that's athletic greens.com slash gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance. So how is it that we set? healthy and realistic boundaries. Often, I think it's through trial and error that we come to realize what boundaries we need in our life. It's when something goes wrong or when we feel disrespected or treated poorly that we fully realize that we need to set up some clearer expectations or that we need to take a stand. I think that can be painful, right? We don't realize that something's
you a free one-year supply of immune-supporting vitamin D and five free travel packs with your first purchase. All you have to do is visit athletic greens.com slash gemma. Again, that's athletic greens.com slash gemma to take ownership over your health and pick up the ultimate daily nutritional insurance. So how is it that we set? healthy and realistic boundaries. Often, I think it's through trial and error that we come to realize what boundaries we need in our life. It's when something goes wrong or when we feel disrespected or treated poorly that we fully realize that we need to set up some clearer expectations or that we need to take a stand. I think that can be painful, right? We don't realize that something's|||首单购买即可获赠一年免费的免疫支持维生素 D 以及五包免费旅行装。你所需要做的就是访问 athleticgreens.com/gemma。再次强调，那是 athleticgreens.com/gemma，以掌控你的健康并挑选终极的日常营养保险。那么我们究竟该如何设定健康且现实的边界呢？通常，我认为是通过反复试验，我们才意识到我们在生活中需要什么样的边界。当事情出错或者当我们感到不受尊重或受到恶劣对待时，我们才充分意识到我们需要建立更清晰的期望，或者我们需要表明立场。我认为这可能会很痛苦，对吧？我们并没有意识到有什么不对劲
wrong until it's really wrong. But I think it's also important to understand the emotional consequences of when we don't have those clear boundaries and when we keep letting ourselves be mistreated. I'm sure we all know someone who is always working late hours, even when they have other commitments or maybe a friend who always lets their partner or another friend criticize or take advantage of them with little to no consequences and at their expense. And in those situations where we haven't taken the time to set up and communicate a clear boundary with someone and be like, hey, I don't like it when you treat me that way.
wrong until it's really wrong. But I think it's also important to understand the emotional consequences of when we don't have those clear boundaries and when we keep letting ourselves be mistreated. I'm sure we all know someone who is always working late hours, even when they have other commitments or maybe a friend who always lets their partner or another friend criticize or take advantage of them with little to no consequences and at their expense. And in those situations where we haven't taken the time to set up and communicate a clear boundary with someone and be like, hey, I don't like it when you treat me that way.|||直到它真的出错了。但我认为，理解当我们没有这些清晰的边界并且一直让自己受到虐待时的情感后果也很重要。我确信我们都认识这样的人：他们总是工作到很晚，即使他们有其他的承诺，或者也许是一个朋友，总是让他们的伴侣或其他朋友批评他们或占他们的便宜，却几乎没有或根本没有后果，并且以牺牲他们自己为代价。在那些我们没有花时间与某人建立并沟通清晰边界、表现得像“嘿，我不喜欢你那样对待我”的情况下。
I expect you to treat me differently. You cannot, you know, message my work phone after 9pm, whatever it may be. When we don't do that, the outcomes can be pretty severe. fear. You know, you may feel really frustrated, really anxious or angry or guilty. There's just this whole spectrum of emotions because our very personhood, our sense of self, feels violated because we don't feel respected. And often these emotions themselves are a sign that you need a boundary. Because no one's behaviour should be making you feel that way. And no one's way of treating you or approaching you should be putting you in a position where you're dealing with
I expect you to treat me differently. You cannot, you know, message my work phone after 9pm, whatever it may be. When we don't do that, the outcomes can be pretty severe. fear. You may feel really frustrated, really anxious or angry or guilty. There's just this whole spectrum of emotions because our very personhood, our sense of self, feels violated because we don't feel respected. And often these emotions themselves are a sign that you need a boundary. Because no one's behaviour should be making you feel that way. And no one's way of treating you or approaching you should be putting you in a position where you're dealing with|||我希望你以不同的方式对待我。你知道的，晚上 9 点以后你不能给我工作手机发信息，无论具体内容是什么。当我们不这样做时，后果可能会相当严重。害怕。你可能会感到非常沮丧、非常焦虑、愤怒或内疚。这里有一整套的情绪，因为我们的个人尊严、我们的自我意识感到了侵犯，因为我们觉得没有受到尊重。通常这些情绪本身就是你需要边界的信号。因为任何人的行为都不应该让你产生那种感觉。任何人的对待你或接近你的方式都不应该让你处于必须处理
really heavy and hard emotions. Having positive boundaries, it means that you're confident in saying no to others and you're able to separate your thoughts and your emotions from those of other people. You don't feel guilty about disappointing them. You don't feel guilty about standing up for yourself, even if it means maybe embarrassing them a little bit. I think many of us struggle with our boundaries because of that reason, right? We don't want to upset someone. We don't want to put them in a position where they feel as if they've done something wrong and out of a care and a caution around our relationships. We allow ourselves to be passive in the face of, not always disrespect, but in the face of behaviours that we really don't want to tolerate. I saw
really heavy and hard emotions. Having positive boundaries, it means that you're confident in saying no to others and you're able to separate your thoughts and your emotions from those of other people. You don't feel guilty about disappointing them. You don't feel guilty about standing up for yourself, even if it means maybe embarrassing them a little bit. I think many of us struggle with our boundaries because of that reason, right? We don't want to upset someone. We don't want to put them in a position where they feel as if they've done something wrong and out of a care and a caution around our relationships. We allow ourselves to be passive in the face of, not always disrespect, but in the face of behaviours that we really don't want to tolerate. I saw|||非常沉重和艰难情感的境地。拥有积极的边界，意味着你自信地对他人说不，并且你能够将你的思想和情感与他人的思想和情感分离开来。你不会因为让他们失望而感到内疚。你不会因为为自己挺身而出而感到内疚，即使这意味着可能会让他们感到有点尴尬。我认为我们中的许多人由于这个原因而在边界问题上苦苦挣扎，对吧？我们不想惹恼某人。我们不想让他们处于一种觉得自己做错了什么的境地，并且出于对关系的关心和谨慎。面对不一定总是缺乏尊重、但却是我们真正不想容忍的行为时，我们让自己处于被动状态。我看到
this really interesting study, and it said that women in particular really struggle with this, because we have been conditioned in many ways to believe that the needs of others are more important than our own. And so we tend to appease. We tend to put others' needs in front of our own and not really take care of ourselves physically and mentally, and don't really set boundaries about how we expect to be treated. So the first thing to do, I think, is to identify what it is about a situation that makes you upset and what exactly it was, whether it was something someone has said, an action, a behaviour that's left you feeling that way.
this really interesting study, and it said that women in particular really struggle with this, because we have been conditioned in many ways to believe that the needs of others are more important than our own. And so we tend to appease. We tend to put others' needs in front of our own and not really take care of ourselves physically and mentally, and don't really set boundaries about how we expect to be treated. So the first thing to do, I think, is to identify what it is about a situation that makes you upset and what exactly it was, whether it was something someone has said, an action, a behaviour that's left you feeling that way.|||这项非常有趣的研究，它说尤其是女性在这一点上真的很挣扎，因为我们在许多方面都被灌输了一种观念：认为别人的需求比我们自己的更重要。因此我们往往会迎合。我们往往把别人的需求放在我们自己之前，却并没有真正在身心上照顾好自己，也没有真正就我们期望被对待的方式设定边界。所以我认为首先要做的是，找出某种情况下是什么让你心烦意乱，以及它到底是什么，无论是某人说过的话、一个动作、一种让你有这种感觉的行为。
Ultimately, I think boundaries speak to what makes us feel good and comfortable. So if something is making you uncomfortable, it's likely that it's crossed a boundary. that you haven't even been able to identify yet. And at this stage, it's really important to think through, why did that happen? What was triggering about that? What particular element of that person's behavior made me upset? And if I'm thinking about setting a boundary and calling out this behavior,
Ultimately, I think boundaries speak to what makes us feel good and comfortable. So if something is making you uncomfortable, it's likely that it's crossed a boundary. that you haven't even been able to identify yet. And at this stage, it's really important to think through, why did that happen? What was triggering about that? What particular element of that person's behavior made me upset? And if I'm thinking about setting a boundary and calling out this behavior,|||归根结底，我认为边界关乎什么能让我们感觉良好和舒适。所以如果有什么事情让你感到不舒服，那它很可能已经越界了。而你甚至还没能识别出那个边界。在这个阶段，认真思考是非常重要的：为什么会发生这种情况？触发点是什么？那个人的行为中究竟是哪个特定元素让我心烦意乱？如果我在考虑设定边界并指出这种行为，
what is it that you want to accomplish by doing that? And do you think that it's something you're going to be able to do? Do you think that having an open conversation or just saying affirm, know, is that going to allow you to achieve that desired outcome? I think the other important thing to consider when we are thinking about boundaries and how to set them in our personal lives and our private lives is what exactly is the boundary that you want to set and does it directly correlate to the outcome that you want. The boundary, I think, has to be specific to the behavior or action that has caused
what is it that you want to accomplish by doing that? And do you think that it's something you're going to be able to do? Do you think that having an open conversation or just saying affirm, know, is that going to allow you to achieve that desired outcome? I think the other important thing to consider when we are thinking about boundaries and how to set them in our personal lives and our private lives is what exactly is the boundary that you want to set and does it directly correlate to the outcome that you want. The boundary, I think, has to be specific to the behavior or action that has caused|||你通过这样做想要实现什么？你认为这是你能做到的事情吗？你认为进行一次坦诚的对话，或者只是坚定地说不，能让你达到期望的结果吗？我认为我们在考虑边界以及如何在个人生活和私生活中设定边界时，另一个需要考虑的重要事情是：你到底想设定什么边界，它是否与你想要的结果直接相关。我认为边界必须具体针对导致
you to become upset. Otherwise, it's just a boundary for boundary's sake, and it probably won't change much. I think it's important to be very, very clear with ourselves. What is your boundary? Why do you need this boundary? Why is it important? Is it that you don't want your parents to ask about your dating life, or that you need more space or a dedicated alone time from your partner, whatever it may be, you're not going to get anywhere if you're not able to articulate it to yourself to begin with. And I think it's really important to have an understanding of, why do I need this boundary? What need does it serve? Why is it important? And get those things kind of ironed out before you begin to approach the idea of communicating that to another party.
you to become upset. Otherwise, it's just a boundary for boundary's sake, and it probably won't change much. I think it's important to be very, very clear with ourselves. What is your boundary? Why do you need this boundary? Why is it important? Is it that you don't want your parents to ask about your dating life, or that you need more space or a dedicated alone time from your partner, whatever it may be, you're not going to get anywhere if you're not able to articulate it to yourself to begin with. And I think it's really important to have an understanding of, why do I need this boundary? What need does it serve? Why is it important? And get those things kind of ironed out before you begin to approach the idea of communicating that to another party.|||你心烦意乱的行为或动作。否则，这只是为了边界而设定的边界，它可能不会带来多大改变。我认为对自己非常非常诚实是很重要的。你的边界是什么？你为什么需要这个边界？为什么它很重要？是不想让父母过问你的约会生活，还是需要伴侣给予更多的空间或专属的独处时间，无论是什么，如果你一开始就无法对自己阐明这一点，你将一事无成。我认为真正理解这些至关重要：我为什么需要这个边界？它满足了什么需求？为什么它很重要？在开始着手与另一方沟通这个想法之前，先把这些事情梳理清楚。
The next step, I think it's the scary one, is an it. We all knew what was coming. You're going to need to verbalise that boundary to the other person. Otherwise, it's never going to happen. Like I said before, it's a hard truth, but people can't read your mind, and we can't expect them to either. So you will need to verbalise to the other person, what it is you need, what behaviour you're willing to accept and how you want to be treated. I think if you want to maintain the relationship with the person you're speaking to, you're going to need to go in with an approach and try not to blindside them. Often when we are often I think when we have experiences where something offends us or we feel upset,
The next step, I think it's the scary one, is an it. We all knew what was coming. You're going to need to verbalise that boundary to the other person. Otherwise, it's never going to happen. Like I said before, it's a hard truth, but people can't read your mind, and we can't expect them to either. So you will need to verbalise to the other person, what it is you need, what behaviour you're willing to accept and how you want to be treated. I think if you want to maintain the relationship with the person you're speaking to, you're going to need to go in with an approach and try not to blindside them. Often when we are often I think when we have experiences where something offends us or we feel upset,|||下一步，我认为这是可怕的一步。我们都知道接下来会发生什么。你需要向对方用语言表达出那个边界。否则，它永远不会发生。就像我之前说的，这是一个残酷的真相，但人们无法读懂你的心思，我们也不能指望他们能。所以你需要向对方用语言表达：你需要什么，你愿意接受什么行为，以及你希望如何被对待。我认为如果你想维持与交谈对象的这种关系，你需要采取一种方法，尽量不要搞突然袭击。通常当我们——通常我认为当我们经历某些冒司我们、或者让我们感到心烦意乱的事情时，
we have this tendency to be really reactive, particularly when something disrupts our boundaries. Sometimes, I don't know, will be in a situation and that behavior that we dislike might come up, someone might say something or ask something of us, and in that moment we feel like we might burst, especially if it's something that's been bothering us for a while. You know, we're sitting in that situation and we just feel the frustration, like bubbling up. And I would advise you from personal experience to not react immediately. It doesn't mean you can't say anything in the moment, or you need to bite your tongue, but just take a second. so that you don't let your feelings almost blind you or get in the way of achieving the outcome you
we have this tendency to be really reactive, particularly when something disrupts our boundaries. Sometimes, I don't know, will be in a situation and that behavior that we dislike might come up, someone might say something or ask something of us, and in that moment we feel like we might burst, especially if it's something that's been bothering us for a while. You know, we're sitting in that situation and we just feel the frustration, like bubbling up. And I would advise you from personal experience to not react immediately. It doesn't mean you can't say anything in the moment, or you need to bite your tongue, but just take a second. so that you don't let your feelings almost blind you or get in the way of achieving the outcome you|||我们往往会做出非常本能的反应，特别是当有什么事情破坏了我们的边界时。有时，我不知道，我们会处于某种情境中，我们不喜欢的那种行为可能会出现，某人可能会说些什么或对我们提出要求，在那一刻我们觉得自己可能会爆发，尤其是如果那是困扰了我们一段时间的事情。你知道的，我们坐在那种情境中，我们只感觉到挫败感在像冒泡一样涌上来。根据个人经验，我建议你不要立即做出反应。这并不意味着你当时什么也不能说，或者你需要忍气吞声，但只要花上一秒钟。这样你就不会让你的情感几乎蒙蔽你的双眼，或者阻碍你实现你想要的
want, take a deep breath and then say something. The worst thing you can do, especially if it's a relationship you want to maintain, is say something that you don't mean or something that you might regret out of anger. You're still able to stand up for yourself, and I think you're doing more of a service if you go into it rationally. Eventually though, you know, you're going to have to have a conversation and in that conversation be really clear with the other person about what it is that you want. What is it about the behaviour or the action that it's upset you and why that needs to change? This is like a really common strategy in couples counselling actually and that's to use eye language. So like I feel bad when you put me down. I feel stressed when you want me to reply
想一想，深吸一口气，然后再说。你能做的最糟糕的事，尤其是如果这段关系你想维持的话，就是在愤怒中说出并非你本意的话，或是日后可能会后悔的话。你依然有权利为自己挺身而出，而且我认为，如果你能保持理性地去沟通，其实是在帮更大的忙。不过最终，你知道的，你还是得和对方谈一谈，并在谈话中向对方明确表达你究竟想要什么。到底是对方的什么行为或举动惹恼了你，为什么这个行为需要改变？这其实是夫妻咨询中非常常见的一个策略，那就是使用“我”开头的语言。比如：当你不尊重我时，我会觉得很难过。当你要求我立刻回复消息时，我会感到压力山大。
instantly. I feel upset or angry when you ask me about my dating life or when you make comments about my weight. And by using that eye language, it makes sure that the other person doesn't feel defensive, rather they feel receptive to what you're saying, which is a positive out of for everyone. Also try and use succinct clear phrases to clarify exactly why you feel this way and why you feel the need to set this boundary. I think there's nothing that healthy, open communication cannot do, especially if it's someone who cares about us, who cares about you, who cares about your relationship. And if it is the case that that person does react negatively, Well, I do think that's highly indicative that there's a deeper lack of disrespect.
当你打听我的感情生活，或者对我的身材评头论足时，我会感到难过或愤怒。通过使用“我”开头的语言，可以确保对方不会感到是在被防御，相反，他们会更能接受你所说的话，这对每个人来说都是一个积极的结果。同时，尽量使用简洁明了的短语，精确阐明你为什么会有这种感受，以及你为什么觉得有必要划定这条界限。我认为，没有什么问题是健康、坦诚的沟通解决不了的，尤其是当对方是在乎我们的人，在乎你、在乎你们关系的人。如果对方确实做出了消极的反应，那么我认为这很能说明问题，说明他们骨子里其实缺乏尊重。
Or maybe there are other things that need to be addressed. It's also very normal that have to reiterate it. Maybe a couple of times, I wouldn't go above like one or two. Or maybe you will have to correct their behavior. But if it does keep happening and they don't apologize or they don't actively seek to change and they keep crossing your boundary, maybe it's time for more drastic measures. I think it's worth noting here that people with healthy boundaries are able to adjust their boundary
或者也许还有其他问题需要解决。不得不重复强调你的界限，这也是非常正常的。也许重复个一两次，我不会超过一两次。或者你可能需要纠正他们的行为。但如果这种情况持续发生，而他们既不道歉，也没有积极寻求改变，并且不断触碰你的底线，也许是时候采取更极端的措施了。我认为这里值得一提的是，拥有健康界限的人能够根据情况调整自己的界限，以适应，我想说的是，适当程度的连接。你知道，在实践中，我们会有意识或无意识地使用界限来决定什么能让我们感到舒适，而在日常生活中，这种标准可能会改变。有时你可能会设立非常严格的界限，比如“绝对不能跨过这条线”。但有时，确保我们的界限不会过于死板也很重要。而另一方面，当我们的界限太具有渗透性、太灵活时，我们往往会任由别人占我们便宜，或者接受我们本不该承受的对待。这就好象我们根本没有界限一样。
depending on a situation to allow for, I would say, like the appropriate level of connection. You know, in practice we consciously and unconsciously use boundaries to decide what allows us to feel comfortable and on a daily basis that might change. but you might have a very strict, like, do not go past this point type of setup. But sometimes it's important to make sure that our boundaries aren't too strict. And on the flip side, like when our boundaries are too permeable, when they're too flexible, often we tend to let people take advantage of us or accept treatment that we don't deserve. It's like we don't have a boundary at all.
所以，关键在于找到那个中间地带，对吧？既能获得我们应得的尊重，又能理解人无完人，并根据环境做出调整。当我们处于建立健康界限的过程中时，很自然地，那些习惯了你某种行为的人，习惯了可以对你为所欲为、或者习惯了占你便宜的人，会感到生气。有些人甚至可能继续不尊重你的界限。他们可能永远不会支持你的需求。我认为在这些情况下，当你觉得：“噢，你知道的，我和伴侣或朋友划定了这条界限，但他们却一再试探、一再践踏，他们依然...”，
So it's about finding that middle ground, right, where we're able to receive the respect we deserve, but we're also able to understand that people make mistakes and adapt to our circumstances. When we're in the process of establishing healthy boundaries, I think naturally, the people that are used to you behaving some way, the people who are used to being able to say whatever they want, or to take advantage of you, they're going to get upset. And some people might even continue to disrespect your boundaries. They might never be supportive. of what you need. I think in these instances when you feel like, oh, you know, I set this boundary with my partner or with my friend, and they just keep pushing it. They keep violating it. They still
依然对我说那些话。他们依然未经允许就开我的车，或者依然对我的事情评头论足，打扰我的个人和自由时间。有时我们会觉得，问题出在自己身上，而不是他们。但事实绝对不是这样的。你值得被你所希望的方式对待。因此，在那些你觉得自己信念动摇的时刻，一定要向自己重申：当初你为什么觉得有必要设立这条界限？你在保护自己免受什么伤害？或者你在为自己争取什么？你现在依然有这种需求吗？我猜答案很可能是“是”，对吧？你知道的，每个人都有被尊重的需求，都有被以他们应得的方式对待的需求。
keep saying those things to me. They still keep using my car without asking or they still keep making comments about this or interrupting my personal and my free time. Sometimes we can feel, you know, like the problem is me, not them. And that's definitely not the case. You deserve to be treated the way that you want to be treated. So in those instances where you feel your resolve cracking, really reiterate to yourself why it is that you felt the need to enact that boundary in the first place. What were you protecting yourself from or providing for yourself? And do you still have that need? I'm guessing the answer is probably yes, right? You know, everyone has a need to feel respected and a need to feel like they're treated the way they deserve.
所以，如果你已经划定了界限，也进行了沟通，而你生命中的某个人无论如何都无法尊重这一点，也许是时候考虑其他选择了。这就把我们带到了下一个难题，对吧？当有人不断触犯你的底线时，你该怎么办？当有人越过我们的界限时，会引发许多情绪。大多数时候，你知道的，那是愤怒。那是愤怒，是悲伤。
So if it's the case that you've set the boundary, you've had the conversation, and there's someone in your life who just, no matter what, can't seem to respect that, maybe it's time to consider some other options. So that leads us to our next conundrum, right? What do you do when someone continues to violate your boundaries. When someone crosses our boundaries, it can create a lot of emotions. Most of the time, you know, it's anger. It's anger. It's sadness.
是焦虑，是恐惧。我有一个小故事想分享给你，希望对你有所帮助。那是一个我与一个非常亲密的人相处的故事，我发现对方一再不尊重我试图与之建立的界限。我和一个朋友之间就遇到过这种情况，当时她正经历一段非常艰难的时期。你知道吗，这没关系。我认为我们都会经历这样的时期。但她对我的依赖相当不健康，在某些方面真的开始扰乱我的生活，让我感到非常沮丧，而且我根本帮不了这个人。最后我发现自己...
It's anxiety. It's fear. I have this anecdote for you, and I hope it will be useful. And it's of a time when I repeatedly found someone I was really close to not respecting a boundary. I was actively trying to set with them. So I had this with a friend and they were going through a really difficult time. And you know what, that's fine. I think we all go through periods like that. But her reliance on me was quite unhealthy and was really beginning to disturb my life in some ways in a way that was really upsetting and I couldn't help this person. And I got to the point where I
会收到一些让我情绪崩溃的信息，里面全都是极其情绪化、极具攻击性的内容。我每天早上醒来，就会担心这个人是不是在夜里给我发了什么非常创伤性的内容，或者试图打电话给我，或者发了一条极具攻击性的短信。我时刻处于高度戒备状态，随时准备承载她的情感包袱，而且往往是她在任何时刻的怒火。情况发展到让我感到极其压力山大和强烈的地步，甚至达到了精神极度痛苦的程度，我真的无法处理自己生活中的一切...
would be receiving these messages that would just send me into like a tizzy and it would just be incredibly emotional content, incredibly aggressive content. And I would wake up in the morning and I would just be fearful that this person overnight had sent me something really traumatic or tried to call me or had sent me a really aggressive text message. And I was on high alert to take on their emotional baggage and often their anger at any given point. And it got to this point of being incredibly stressful and intense for me, like to a point of like intense mental distress where I genuinely could not manage everything going on in my life
以及这段友情。我和这个人沟通过几次，也向她重申了我无法进行这些高强度的讨论，也无法接收这些信息，并且建议她最好去看心理医生，因为我实在没有能力也没有技巧去处理这些。尽管如此，那条界限并没有被尊重。那条“我无法成为你这种支柱”的界限...
and this friendship. And I talked and communicated to this person a few times about this and reiterated that I couldn't have these intense discussions or receive these messages and it would be good for her to maybe get some professional help because I just didn't have the capacity or the skills to do it. And despite that, that boundary was not respected. That boundary of being like, I cannot be this person for you.
“请不要把我当成你的治疗师或心理学家。请不要给我发这些信息。”它没有被尊重。这真的很难，因为我希望她能对我好点。我希望能拥有一段健康的感情。所以，在那些无论你做什么，都发现这些人或这个人不断侵犯你的私人空间或你根本无法接受的禁区时，我们该怎么办？
Please do not treat me like your therapist or like your psychologist. Please don't send me these messages. It wasn't respected. And that was really hard because I wanted her to treat me well. I wanted to have a healthy relationship. So what do we do in those situations when no matter what you do, you just find that these people or this person, person keeps encroaching on the space or the no-go zone where you really don't feel comfortable.
我意识到的一点是，你无法控制别人，也无法强迫他们变成他们不是的那种人。再说一次，你知道的，你只能控制你自己，并教会别人如何对待你。但如果他们不愿吸取教训，那也许是时候采取更极端的措施了。如果你已经试图心平气和地让对方知道他们的所作所为是不对的，他们越界了，这是对你很重要的事情，是你希望得到尊重的事情，那么也许是时候重新审视他们的行为以及他们对你的态度了。重要的是，有时候你必须接受这样一种现实：无论你做什么，人们都不会尊重你的界限。这是一个极其残酷的真相，因为我认为我们总是倾向于把人往好处想，真心想给别人第二次、第三次、甚至是第四次机会。所以意识到这一点会让人感到非常失望，
Something I realized is that you can't control other people or make them someone that they're not. Once again, you know, you only get to control yourself and teach people how to treat you. But if they won't take that lesson, then maybe it's time for something more drastic. if you've tried to calmly let the person know that what they did wasn't okay, that they violated your boundary, that this is something that's important to you, something that you would like to be respected, maybe it's time to rethink their behavior and time to rethink their attitude towards you. Importantly, sometimes you've just got to accept that people are not going to respect your boundaries no matter what you do. And this is such a difficult truth because I think we like to think that the best of people and we really want to give people second, third, sometimes fourth chances. So it can be really disappointing to realize this
并且必须根据这种认识做出艰难的决定：这个人其实根本不在乎我是否感到被尊重。他们其实根本不在乎我对自己的看法，也不在乎我希望被如何对待。但这就是你登场的时候了，对吧？你有主动权去选择是接受这种行为，还是准备抽身离开。从一开始就在心里对以下情况设立一个明确的后果，这也是很重要的：
and to have to make a hard decision from this realization that this person actually doesn't care whether I feel respected. They actually don't care what I have to say for myself and how I want to be treated. but here is where you come in, right? You have the agency to choose whether you accept that behavior or whether you're ready to disengage. It's also important from the get-go to have a clear consequence in your mind
如果真的发生了这种情况，如果有人真的越过了这条界限，你将如何反应？要有意识地把这一点写下来，承认它，并在你觉得界限被侵犯时坚决执行这个后果。通常这意味着，你知道的，减少与他们的联系，拉黑他们，把他们从你的生活中剔除。
for how are you going to react if this does happen, if someone does cross this boundary, and be intentional with writing that down, acknowledging it, and enacting that consequence. when you feel the boundary has been crossed. Often that means, you know, reducing your contact with them, blocking them, cutting them out of your life.
这也归结于对自己有一个清晰的认知：你愿意接受什么样的对待，又绝不接受什么。我认为这种觉悟不会轻易到来，对吧？这不是说你某天醒来突然就会想：“哦天哪，我终于意识到我值得被温柔以待了。”它是随着时间和成熟度一点点积累的，而且我认为它伴随着我们刚才讨论过的那些试错经历，对吧？如果你被差劲地对待了足够多的次数，你最终会对此感到有点厌烦。然后你开始意识到：“哦，在这种情况下，我大概应该为自己挺身而出了。”
This also comes down to being really clear with yourself about what treatment you're willing to accept and what you don't. I don't think that realization comes easily, right? It's not something that you're going to wake up one day and be like, oh my gosh, I finally realized that I deserve to be treated well. But it comes with time and with maturity, and I think with some of those trial and error experiences like we were talking about, right? If you're treated poorly enough times, eventually you get a little bit sick of it. And you start to realize like, oh, I should probably be standing up for myself in this instance.
有时候，除了放手，别无他法。你知道的，我坚信大多数人并不是什么有毒的或糟糕的人（除了那些患有严重人格障碍的人，比如自恋狂或反社会人格障碍）。但即使在那种情况下，他们也不是坏人，而是一种疾病。而且，你知道的，那是完全不同的另一码事。但我确实相信，诸如此类的行为或有毒状态——比如不断侵犯你的界限——并不是你的错，也不是因为他们是坏人。这通常是因为他们自身有什么问题没有得到解决。也许是他们无法尊重自己。归根结底，这是他们的损失。如果他们必须放弃与你的关系，天哪，那是他们的损失，
And sometimes there's nothing left to do but let go. You know, I firmly believe that most people are not toxic or bad people, you know, with the exception of people with severe person. personality disorders like narcissism or psychopathy, but even in those instances, like they're not bad people, it's a condition. And, you know, that's a whole other ballgame entirely. But I do believe that behavior like this or toxicity, like the continual violation of your boundaries, it's not your fault and it's not because they're a bad person. It's normally due to something that they're not addressing. Maybe it's their inability to respect themselves. And ultimately, it's their loss. If they have to give up a relationship with you, oh my gosh, that's their loss,
绝对是的。因为归根结底，你确实值得被尊重、被爱、被以你希望的方式对待。无论这个人是你的同事、朋友、家庭成员，甚至是伴侣，都无法改变这样一个事实：你值得被尊重，并以你希望的方式被对待。不过话说回来，有时你确实不得不切断联系，以此来保护自己并掌控自己的幸福。这可能是一个非常艰难的决定，我想我们任何人都不会轻易做出。所以我真的建议你确保自己已经探索过了所有机会。
absolutely. Because at the end of the day, you really do deserve to be respected and loved and treated how you want to be treated. Regardless of whether this person is a colleague, is a friend or a family member, even a partner, that doesn't change that fact that you deserve to be treated and respected the way that you want to be treated. But still, sometimes you do have to cut off contact in order to protect yourself and take control of your happiness. And that can be a really hard decision and not what I think any of us would take lightly. So I would really make sure that you've explored or opportunities.
并且这也将带给你想要的结局。与这个人断绝联系、对他们说再见，才是能让你更快乐、让你的生活变得更好的选择。我认为，如果你能与那个人进行最后一次谈话，谈谈为什么必须如此，并看看能否从他们那里得到哪怕一点点认可，认识到他们的行为正在对你造成伤害。如果不能，你知道的，你做了你该做的事，大概是时候说再见了。我明白这说起来容易做起来难，尤其是当我们想到家庭的时候。我敢肯定，我们很多人都曾不得不对家人划定界限。当这些界限被打破时，
And also that it's going to give you the outcome that you want. That cutting this person off, that saying goodbye to them is what's, going to make you happier and is going to leave your life in a better place. I think if you can have one final conversation with that person about why this needs to happen and just see if you can get any of that recognition from them that their behaviour is causing you harm. And if not, you know, you did what you needed to do and it's probably time to say goodbye, which I know is a lot easier said than done, especially when we think about, you know, family. I'm sure many of us have had to set boundaries with our family members. And when they've
我们不得不做出艰难的决定。所以，即使是在较小的规模上，我也绝对不羡慕你。你知道的，今年年初我和一个约会对象就经历过这种情况。我当时设立的界限是：如果要和这个人约会，我需要感觉到他们尊重我、想让我陪伴在身边。我把这一点传达给了他们，但他们从来没有做到过。他们从未让我感到被尊重。甚至在我多次表达过这一点之后也是如此。最后，我不得不离开。我不得不说：“很抱歉，你不能再成为我生活的一部分了。”天哪，真的太难了。我记得当时进行那次对话时泪流满面。但与此同时，我也从未感到如此为自己骄傲，因为我终于意识到了自己配得上什么，以及我期望那些声称爱我的人如何对待我。
been violated, we've had to make hard decisions. So I definitely don't envy you, even on a smaller scale. You know, I had to do this with someone I was dating at the start of the year. And I had set this boundary that if I were to date this person, I needed to feel like they respected me and wanted me around and I communicated that to them and they never did. They never made me feel respected. Even after I'd express that many times. And finally, I just had to go. I had to be like, I'm sorry you can't be part of my life anymore. And oh my God, it was so hard. I remember having that conversation and just being in tears. But I'd also never felt more proud of myself, Phil, finally realizing what I deserved and how I expected to be treated by people who claim to love me.
这简直是最赋能的时刻之一，是我与自己关系的一个转折点。我给了自己时间去为那段关系的结束感到悲伤。但我也为自己感到悲伤——为我居然容忍那种行为那么久、让一条重要的界限被践踏而感到难过。所以，如果你正处于那个阶段，如果你正面临这种两难境地，如果你已经完成了所有这些步骤，对吧？你扪心自问过：对方的这种行为到底哪里惹恼了我？这个界限真的能带给我想要的结局吗？我该如何设立这个界限？我已经和他们谈过了。
It was like one of the most empowering moments, a turning point in my relationship with myself. And I gave myself time to grieve that relationship. But I also gave myself time to grieve and be sad about the fact that I had let that behavior gone for so long, that I had let an important boundary be crossed. So if you're at that stage, if you're having this dilemma, if you've done all those steps, right, you've thought to yourself, what is it about this behavior that's upsetting me? Will this boundary actually give me the outcome that I want? How can I set this boundary? I've had this conversation with them.
我已经明确表达了他们身上究竟是什么行为惹恼了我，然而即便如此，依然什么都没有改变。也许你已经到了那种“什么都不会改变”的地步，对吧？就像你无法改变这个人一样。你只能改变你的环境，只能为你自己做出决定。所以我觉得这始终是需要考虑的一点，特别是在我们谈论非常严重的界限问题时。无论如何，希望你喜欢这一期节目。内容有点深刻，也有点情绪化。我觉得每次分享一大堆个人轶事时好像都是这样。我总是会想：“哦哇，这一周的节目我真的太能感同身受了。”而这期似乎就是其中之一。所以希望正在收听节目的你，
I've communicated clearly what it is about their behavior that upsets me and still, still nothing has changed. Maybe you're at that point where nothing is going to change. right? Like you can't change this person. You can only change your environment and you can only make the decisions for yourself. So I think it's always something to consider, especially when we talk about really serious boundaries as well. Anyhow, I hope that you liked this episode. It was kind of deep, kind of emotional. I feel like that's always the case. I always notice it when I share heaps of personal anecdotes. I'm like, oh wow, I could really relate to this episode. this week and seems that this was one of those. So I hope that if you're listening and you're
如果在考虑假期期间、或是人际关系中的界限问题时，这期内容能对你有所帮助，能让你学到东西——甚至在研究这个话题时，我自己也学到了东西，学到了超级有用的东西。我认为这真是一个非常有价值的学习资源，或者说是一种很有价值的见解、宝贵的知识。非常感谢你的收听。如果你喜欢这一期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在正在收听的平台上留下五星好评。这真的对节目的成长很有帮助，能让它被更多人听到。今年真的是疯狂的一年。感谢所有已经留下评价的人。这简直让我感动不已，我真的非常、非常感激。如果你想对明年播出的节目主题发表意见，
thinking about boundaries around the holiday season, around your relationships, that this was helpful that you learned something, even researching this, like I learned something, I learned something super helpful. And I think it's just such a valuable kind of learning resource or like a valuable insight to have, valuable knowledge. So thank you so much for listening. listening. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave it a five-star review on Apple, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really helps the show grow. It helps it reach new people. This has been such a crazy year. Thank you to everyone who's already left a review. It's like overwhelming. And I really, really appreciate it. If you want to have a say over
那就去Instagram上关注我吧，账号是That Psychology Podcast。我每周都会在那里发布一个投票，来决定那一周的节目我要录制什么内容。所以如果你想参与的话，就去点个关注吧。如果不想也没关系。感谢大家一路陪伴这段旅程。希望大家在假期来临之前，都能学到一些关于界限的知识。我知道对我们许多人来说，这是一段艰难的时光。祝你好运。节日快乐。非常感谢你的收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些磨难，
what episodes I publish next year. Well, follow me on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I put out a poll there every week to decide what I record for one of those episodes that week. So go and give it a follow if you want to, if that's something you want to do. If not, that's all right. Thanks for coming along for the journey. And I hope everyone learned something about boundaries before the holiday season. I know For many of us, it is a hard time. So best of luck. Happy holidays. And thank you so much for listening. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships
你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWO%。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
对于1979年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员，
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians,
以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯。
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神盔甲？它向世界释放的信号是：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着你需要这样做。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试不止一次，对吗？
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct?
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the first. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档IHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。